this will not be my campaign this will
be our campaign all together it was the
announcement former president Donald
Trump made despite advisors suggesting
it wasn't a good idea in order to make
America great and glorious again I am
tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
it was also the announcement his
supporters have been waiting for
outside Mar-A-Lago only a few dozen
Trump supporters were out but they had
plenty to say he's still our president
he never can he never stopped it's just
unfortunate that things took place the
way they did but he never took
concession he still is the president he
still is the commander-in-chief no one
respects the current president uh world
leaders think of him as weak and that's
just not the man we need right now
the Republican party was hoping that a
red wave during midterm elections would
solidify their standing in the 2024
presidential election but many of the
congressional candidates that Trump
backed including those in key States
lost in a stunning fashion
he's facing multiple investigations on
different fronts Congressional hearings
are ongoing into Trump's involvement in
the January 6 Capital riots Liz Cheney a
member of Congress who's on the
investigating committee says Trump is
detached from reality it's also really
important for people to to look at
what's happening and what he's doing not
just through a political lens but
through the basic facts of his total
um
lack of Fitness for office he's unstable
he's also being investigated for his
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
results and his handling of classified
documents that were seized from his
Mar-A-Lago estate
he also faces several criminal
investigations involving his Trump
organization all that didn't seem to
deter Trump from standing in his resorts
in West Palm Beach Florida and
proclaiming that he is the only
candidate the Republicans should support
despite the disunity within the
Republican party over whether or not to
support Trump for president he's still
very popular with a lot of Republican
voters it's a base that other Republican
candidates will definitely want to tap
into
Rhonda Sanchez just won a landslide
re-election as governor of Florida he
was once a trump loyalist but is now
increasingly seen as Trump's biggest
rival for the Republican nomination and
Governor DeSantis is in violation of his
oath of office what he claims all the
other people have done such as with the
buses still here in Palm Beach County
where they make you wear a mask that
they're in violation will so was he
Trump's a wrecking ball in the system I
think that a lot of people agree that we
can't trust the media anymore I think
that a lot of people agree that we can't
trust the people in power anymore I love
Trump because he also he is the very
first president to acknowledge black
people
also once an Ardent supporter his former
vice president Mike Pence who had this
to say when asked if Trump should be
president again I think that's up to the
American people
but I think we'll have better choices in
the future
decide who they want to lead the country
next but will the fragile Republican
party be able to come together to back
the same candidate there are still
millions of Americans who support Donald
Trump and many others who want to see
him go away
Renee O'Day Al Jazeera West Palm Beach
Florida